okay lost pot now again the important
part of this is well how do i how do i
child a path through here right how do I
use the information I've got to get to
something what is the something above
them it's the radius so I better put the
radius on here okay look at where my
second is I think it's something like
this yeah do you mean for this last part
you would get some marks but I don't
think you'd get all them because you
don't need to you don't need to you can
get it as an exact number without any
treatment
okay I wouldn't I would I would doubt
you get 0 if everything you've done is
valid but you can go further you can get
much simpler so they form expectant your
needs me now so far I've avoided using
any extra protein rules or anything like
that like I haven't even called that the
alpha or you know whatever but I am
gonna call this one up because it will
get a bit messy in a second okay so I
just found out that this was route 21
okay I just I just showed that at Oise
and this is why I love to know so the
important part of the question is how am
I gonna get from the information I know
keep in mind I've just been using the
cosine rule a heck of a lot I can do it
again right I can totally do it again
look in this triangle why I'm after
really is science okay in fact I want to
get all three sides because once I do I
just want to know all of them okay if I
need sides then what's the opposite part
of the cosine rule it's not science it's
its angle okay so when you look at this
you've got three angles to choose from
okay let's count it up you got this one
right
do you got this one which is the same
and then you've got this one in the
middle okay now I can use any of those
three two which seems like a more
obvious easier to access choice is it
the base angles or is it the other angle
now I would suggest it looks to me and I
hope you can see it on your diagram this
angle over here is going to be easier to
access okay keep in mind I found out
what this angle was right I did it
earlier that means I know what this
angle is but this angle is related to
the angle and try and find but what's
the relationship between these two guys
very good very good
this standing on the same arc see that
CED CED busy aren't there these guys
sent us and these guys at the
circumference sorry I am using CD I'm
gonna need them I'm gonna need blades
this guy here you talking about that one
I don't know what it is oh you mean like
different awesome like I mean yeah I
can't which is fine though you know same
radius okay you can do that the reason
why I went in this direction you my
actually didn't even didn't even say
that is because I've just found CD so
seem natural to just do a progression
from me like all I just found this okay
because I guess if you do if you
construct data then you're ignoring this
reliance you use route 21 to find this
Canyon okay well why don't you judge for
me I'll show you there for now I'm gonna
puff no I'm gonna pop right this angle
is this angle double it will give me the
same okay so here we go I'm ready to go
on that angle in the middle the one I'm
interested in I'm gonna call this the
Centaur okay I'll try okay
oh it's DC its relationship to that
angle over there is its double CBD is
what it's called because that's the one
inside the circle what's my really good
angle that the center is double the
angle of the circle
it's okay so you can go ahead you can
rest it now I think we do it quite well
so you've got that but but CBD is
actually ABC it's different name for the
same angle and I proved earlier on with
my right did I buy it no I just never
actually broke down because I said you
know we can get on with this from here
good morning from here from these
similar triangles right I can identify
these guys here they're equal to each
other right so I'm just going to say
that's two times ad from the outside
that you know from the outside it's it's
bourbon and now okay all right now to ad
you go see now keep in mind you see how
I keep doing this you're looking at what
you got and you're looking at me going
I'm gonna use the cosine rule of the
stock right so I might as well find
cause of this right now okay
cuz of the left-hand side is because of
the right-hand side helps you down the
Krakens face in the reflection okay now
this is great this is great because I
know what caused a TV is so what's the
relationship between these two guys what
I did is this double angle right now I
can choose cos square minus sine squared
or 1 minus 2 sine square or 2 cos
squared minus 1 which of those is the
best choice
yeah the one with cosines in it right so
I'm going to like to call the squared D
take away one yeah yeah I would I would
strongly encourage the use of this one
as opposed to others
okay I know what these numbers are let's
see 2 times 1 4 9 take one that's 8
ninths you take away 1 that's negative
after that no again if you see a
solution right and it's here all the
answers and this is the
and then for some it's the core reason
they're doing cause right you're like
why were they doing that but you were
with me when we started this why am I
doing this again because I'm going to
use the cosine row here so now I know
what I'm going now I'm ready to actually
do it here okay
now interesting way I'm gonna use
something just like this just in a
different triangle I'm still much time
you still at CDT right and I know what
you see is so I'm gonna save you
triangle in B C D I'm going to use the
cosine rule one last time C D swim right
on the science is equal to all right
what what are we gonna have here the
wrench
oh sorry Roman this is not BC its babies
I see Odie okay Stuart Sydney I'm using
this triangle cause it's got the radii
you know right so it's R squared plus R
squared minus two squared cos of this
angle the included angle right yep
and from here it's just the been a leg
work to make ah the subject that's
that's all it is
I know what this is it's 21 one of their
go here to R squared takeaway plus 2r
squared on no double negative
yeah that's 18 R squared of 9 so when I
put it together I'm gonna get 20 R
squared or 9 you read me so far that's
21 and then I'm just gonna make sorry
make us with the subject I couldn't work
out what 9 times 21 is I could but I'm
gonna have to take the square root of
this in a second anyway right
so I'm just gonna leave that as 9 on 20
times 21 so that when I just say ah I
got to swing about so is this going on
longer so that's three I know you're
twenty one's not gonna I'm gonna get
nothing on that
time 7 2020 I can take four out of that
that's too fine and I suppose I could
I couldn't eaten that up a tiny bit by
multiplying by five but I think I do
those is fun this question is not about
rationalizing this question is about
geometry so if you go to that second law
slide I'd be pretty happy